yo man bootleg head podcast
we got the homie from the bay area yes
sir who has very polarizing hip-hop
opinions
homie simba is here what's happening
with you brother what's up man
feeling great thank you for having me
man i'm a big fan of this show
i love the freddie gibbs greg gibbs
episode yeah that was that episode got
sloppy
we drank a whole bottle in 1942 and it
was entertaining and [ __ ]
yeah uh shout out to freddie man cause
he don't got no filter anyway and then
when he's drunk it's uh
there was a lot taken out of that
interview we had to take some [ __ ] out
of here i think freddie we might have
started some wars with that interview
freddie might have it it's i'm going
back and forth with three of them but he
might have album of the year
dude me and you see things the same way
okay
alfredo to me is album of the year what
you what's your three that you're going
back and forth with
see benny just kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] up okay
cause i had i had alfredo
um i had
[Music]
i can't even think off the top right now
but i had alfredo
i had nas in there i had um
i had big sean in there
and it was one more that i can't think
right now at the top of my head but i
had those three for sure but
benny album is like yeah that's dope
i did a list i did a list uh
earlier in the year before a lot of like
big sean and nas dropped
and i had alfredo's one
and then somewhere in there there was
like pray for parish from west side gun
yeah i think run the drills fours though
running joe's was definitely dope
but since then i mean little baby my
turn is not an
album that i necessarily but you got to
give him
his respect that was mine that's the one
you got to put that up it was baby
because for me
i've been listening to little baby since
he first came out right so to hear the
growth
yeah you hear the growth and just not
only his tone and voice but just his
lyrics and beat selection and the way
he's jumping in and out of cadences and
his subject matter
for sure i think uh yeah i think big
sean detroit too uh
is up there for me i just felt like it
was a super vulnerable album definitely
conway [ __ ] it was that time too for
some news
not it's been a great year for hip-hop
but i think that alfredo is still number
one
i'm with you man with you i'm with you
i'm nice not too far off i'm with you
so you're uh you're from the bay from
the bay but you don't make
the music you're a jedi on the mic man i
like to call it
certain rappers jedis olympically you're
special um
why why is it that when i hear your
music i don't necessarily hear the bay
area influence off the rip
um great question
um i grew up like
just bay area to the core you know i
mean white t-shirt blue jeans and nike's
just
three times crazy just listening to all
the bass [ __ ] mac mall
right and um
i think around the hyphy era right when
the hyphy area came
in i started traveling a lot okay like
with my parents my parents was like
heavy in the real estate game
and i tell people all the time i grew up
kind of opposite of how most of my
friends did so a lot of my friends
they had like struggling upbringings
when they was very young
i didn't right my parents kind of met
your parents too yeah my mom's in vegas
so they had [ __ ] going on cardinals won
that game by the way i told his dad
yeah but um they already had things
going on
so we was able to travel a lot so my
parents had homes in like atlantic city
las vegas and we would just move around
and i would notice like
a lot of the songs that i loved back
home
wasn't being played in these other areas
so i would
make friends in vegas and make friends
in atlantic city and make friends in
philly
and i would play these songs and they'd
be like what is this bro what's this
right you know what i'm saying and for a
minute i used to feel like
oh they don't like the beat or they
don't get it or they don't they think
it's
it's like a gimmick or something like
that but what it is is we
we live on like an island right so our
culture is
very just like independent and it's us
to the core
so a lot of people don't really know
about
pimp culture right you know what i mean
a lot of people don't really know about
bipping and you know i mean certain
things we do in the bay
so when we talk about these things in
the songs and in the lyrics the rest of
the world is like what's that like what
is he talking about like i don't get
what he's saying
because it's something they're not used
to seeing every day so when i started
making music
i started like writing from not like a i
perspective
i feel like a lot of artists where i'm
from right from my eye perspective like
i take the [ __ ] i do this i got the
whip i do this i try to rap from like a
wii perspective to where
anybody could see it so it's like i say
lines to where the bear get it it's like
uh
you think you gonna get the pennies if
you make a paddock freeze i could take a
[ __ ] to applebee she won't be mad at me
you know what i'm saying but it's
applebee's everywhere everybody wearing
paddocks
you know what i mean everybody's
spending money on girls get that two for
20 at applebee's man you know what i'm
saying so it's just like i always try to
speak from a perspective of being from
the bay
but where the world could identify with
things i'm saying within the music
yeah i think that the bay is like we
were just talking a little bit about
this but i think the bay
is its own it's it's very
there's the only place that i can kind
of like
on a very s much smaller scale
is i moved to tampa and i went to when i
did radio in tampa for a few years
and when i went to the club there i
heard some [ __ ] called juke music
and it's only in tampa well that [ __ ]
get played
nowhere else it's like a hundred trying
to say it's like a go-go thing it's like
105 bpms with bells in it it's like
it's like it's some [ __ ] it's it's
called tampa juke music
and i was like what what the [ __ ] is
this yeah
and i feel like in the bay it's the
biggest example of that
as far as like except for you know i
i the bay has influenced everybody a lot
i mean no like
i feel like the beta does not get there
just do and i say this all the time i
think the bay
has so much influence on hip hop thanks
and they don't get there not just
hip-hop [ __ ] fashion technology
tech now of course that's passion of
course you know what i mean like
it's a lot more we but i feel like it's
just an
island and it's like okay like
you could go to the bay and there'll be
like there'll be like records that
go up that aren't even necessarily bae
records
that are just so big that you'll be like
yo this song was like
this was a big record like what
you won't even really know like that
yeah like you won't even really notice
something like that unless you come to
the bay
and you see the effect of it so when
you're driving through the bay you're
hearing it on the radio you're seeing
people in the car play
you big you're a big dj so i'm sure
you've had a lot of
dj gigs up there where you're spinning
in the clubs and you
hearing people coming to you telling you
to play records that you might not even
have like what the hell is this you know
that that happened to me one time and
then i
i just i had to be like okay i had to
hit a homie and be like yo i just need
to
i just need the folder of like the odd
records that i should just have on deck
for if i'm ever do and it was like just
gotta have crazy [ __ ]
like trunk boys cupcake no filling bro
[ __ ] that you just would never expect
like
i want to say like baby boy to pray like
just some like random [ __ ] that like
you're like yo i didn't know this song
was a thing like i knew about the song
but i didn't know anywhere
else gave a [ __ ] about it but now i do
think that it's like
you know obviously with the rich history
of the bay is dope that
there is you know for what you do there
is
a dope side of the bay there's you know
back in the 90s there was hyrule
and souls of mischief and all that but i
think that like
you're bringing a lot of people
associate mozzie with the bass from
sacramento thanks
uh shout out to the fella fella too
that's what's up man shout out to mazzy
shout out to sacramento too
but i feel like you're in a dope
position where you're um
you can make music that that
everybody in hip-hop respects and you
also happen to be from the bay
as opposed to like because i think a lot
of times with bay area artists we
associate them with being from the bay
first
and unfortunately there's some sort of
preconceived
stigma that comes with that that you
might have already made up your mind
about that artist even though you
you know that's not fair that's not okay
but i mean it's it's it's
it is what it is it's a life you know i
mean like we look at things and we judge
it sometimes
like 24 karat golden's got the number
one song in the country and i had no
idea
recently you wouldn't know he was from
the bay but it's like he's doing a
different type of thing
you know what i mean most people like
you said you know they're from the bay
because you can hear it in the music
you can hear it in the sound you can
hear it and how they represent
themselves
certain things they may post on
instagram or where they may be
but there's a another level we could
take things to that's a uh
g-eazy level k lonnie level and now at
24k
level so where we could take things to
another level to where the world
could identify with us and rock with us
and we could speak for the bay and be a
platform for other artists in the bay
that want to take it to that same level
yeah um
talk about your situation so i met you
probably like two years ago
you came up to the studio with your boy
who i forget your boy's name he's a
comedian yeah
pj oh luke no lou me and luke shout out
my brother louis built
and um you freestyled i think nico nico
yeah shout out to nico blitz nico blitz
is who put me under here he's from the
bay
yes he had a nico blitz guess what he's
actually
the most cringe cringiest part of the
bay just go on nico's page and you know
whether it's
this fool is fizzing and doing all kinds
of [ __ ] like
just underneath unnecessary he'll throw
ye
on anything he can just unnecessarily
yeah like yo
like what that is why the ye there nico
blitz but that's that's how he is in the
bay like we passionate about it's really
a culture we
i feel like we got everything a culture
has except the flag
right like we got our own type of food
we got our own language
you know i mean the way we move the way
we dress just everything
is that's our language we stand on the
yeez and the
yada means right you know what i mean so
help me understand cause like you came
up and freestyled
and that was about two years ago yeah
i didn't know you had just told me that
you were like you were like around
during the beginning of the young
california yeah yeah
so we can get into it so um kind of give
me yeah give me give me all that your
background like your journey
so basically bro i uh i always been like
doing music i was playing ball and doing
music
after high school i realized i didn't
want to go to college
right it was just like something i
didn't want to do i'm not someone fit
for a school setting
so i was like i'm gonna do music
full-time and i i gained like popularity
in my community very fast and like the
pittsburgh antioch area
so you ever heard of young curt yeah
i was like the label that
pushed young curt okay so it was me it
was kurt it was young d it was a bunch
of us
and i was kind of more so playing the
the executive role and kurt was the
artist so i had to stop
rapping i'm being his hype man at
certain shows doing certain
meetings and everything like that to
where i was just an executive mode
so we kind of had a falling out and i
went back to doing music that's when i
met amen
knickknack and everything and we had
came together i never forget this day it
was at p.f
chains in emeryville it was me amen
charisma
starting six young murph bobby brackens
and i am
suit right wow pillow too and we were
starting this thing called young
california and it was going to be like a
label where we all collabed and did
music and everything
and what happened was about a few weeks
to maybe a month later
beat the [ __ ] up just shot the [ __ ] out
the [ __ ] world
just it just just went out the [ __ ]
world
and that brought a lot of exposure to
the bay it brought a lot of publicity a
lot of publishers started coming out a
lot of these big brands started coming
out
and hbk was at the forefront of that
because they had the
um they had that was really a sue record
too by the way it was a sue record that
i mean if you didn't want to be uh he
didn't want the record
sue was like a real lyrical rapper at
the time he was tripping by the way
like sue was rapping on [ __ ] like jay
electronica exhibit c
[ __ ] [ __ ] like that right so he
didn't want it to be looked at like he
was trying to make it like a
yeah like a sellout record so he let
rance take the record
and rance was a party promoter so ranch
is going to all the parties every
[ __ ] night grabbing the mic
playing this [ __ ] over and over and over
and over right and it just
shoots the [ __ ] up right so it brings a
lot of attention to the bait now you got
50 cent getting on the record ti and
jeezy and pleasure p
and chris brown shout out to jay
valentine who put that together
that jay valentine remix the one i play
yeah yeah that's my dog shout out big
bro
so a lot of that had happened and a lot
of the artists
under that kind of got lost in the sauce
because we just didn't have what hbk had
going on and it was
their time to shine so hbk
took off and um i kind of started
noticing like
they was getting bigger than the bay
right and then you started seeing like g
come out g-eazy comes and then he's
taking everybody on tour you know what i
mean he's
bringing sue he's bringing jay in he's
bringing neff to pharaoh so now we're
starting to get recognition
but it was certain artists who was
getting those looks that wasn't the
people i just named but they were
hitting the ceiling
and i always noticed they would hit this
cylinder get a record they go to
petaluma do shows get a couple thizzler
posts
do a couple summer jams and it was over
there was never nothing after that but
sue and g and everybody that [ __ ] was
still going and i noticed it was going
because they wasn't just
staying in the bay you know i mean they
started moving around and doing
different things
so um at the time i was like
you know doing a little bass [ __ ] you
know we all do scams and
little things that we was doing to get
money saved up enough money and i moved
to la
and the minute i moved here i realized
for the type of music i wanted to make
i wasn't good enough so i met
phonics who had me around like while
he's making no role models for j
cole i'm going to sessions with hit
maker while he's
writing ray shrimmer hits and just like
all these big ass songs and i'm like oh
[ __ ] all i can do is rap
i can't write a hook i don't know how to
structure a song
but if you put on the instrumental i'ma
flame this [ __ ] right and um it
wasn't until i met somebody
around almost around the time when i met
you
the homie d brooks who um is from
chicago does a lot of work with like
dirk and herbo and everybody
and he kind of was the first the first
person to put it in perspective for me
like bro
a lot of your raps is hooks you could
take this part make it the hook
you know what i mean you could move this
over here you could do this and i
started learning how to structure [ __ ]
but then the problem i started having
was i would hear something
and try to duplicate it so one day i'd
be a rapper
and the next day i hear some future [ __ ]
going up and i'm like this is what they
want that's what they want let me do
that
i think that's what a lot of people get
sucked into man yeah
they they they i mean that's dope that
you admit that because a lot of artists
get wrapped up in that it's easy to
super easy
especially if you consume music as a fan
you're like you're waking up
every [ __ ] thursday night at
9 00 p.m or in the morning and you're
looking at the new
[ __ ] music that drops right it's very
hard not to be influenced by it and you
see this [ __ ]
you see it like okay this is what the
[ __ ] works well [ __ ] let me try it let
me do this
you know what i mean and then you try it
and it don't work because it's not it's
not organic
it's not organic right so what i
realized by doing that
i wasn't developing an identity for
myself
so i had to sit back bro and i really
had to think like what is it i want to
do
it's around the time i had met you in
head when y'all had brought me up there
and that goes to show
how real y'all is as djs right right
and not even just dj's just culture
curators to bring somebody who's trying
to figure it out
up there with no record no nothing is
just like [ __ ] the kid could rap let him
come up here yeah you know what i mean
so i appreciate that
but um around that time i started
figuring out like what i really do
great is rap right and i met my homie
cass that you met yeah my producer
he went out to eat and he had two videos
up of me i had this song
out one time where i was singing and
another song where i was rapping
and he put him on two phones and he
asked me which one are you
right and i said i'm the rapper and he
was like then why are you singing
i'm like this what people told me that's
what they like to hear
and he looked at me and he said man i'll
never run from rap
don't ever run from rap you too good of
a rapper to run from rap
and ever since that day uh running from
rap to me started meaning this the first
time i ever said this publicly
is don't run from responsibilities and
principles
right i had a responsibility as a rapper
you know what i mean to be dope and to
be great at that
that's the gift i was given but i'm
running away from it
to try to chase chase what other
people's things is so i'm basing
my values and my expectations based off
what other people was getting rather
than just living in my own truth of what
i am yeah
and the minute i started doing that bro
it was like [ __ ] start clicking i start
realizing like okay i don't want to be
somebody in the streets let me make a
song about that
you know what i mean i don't want to be
selling drugs and scamming my whole life
let me make a song about that
and that's how i started developing a
consistent message and the identity of
what i'm standing on as far as
growth and as a man of doing something
different than what we all
are supposed to do as black men growing
up in impoverished communities
wow man yeah no that's i think that like
what you just said man a lot of
artists can relate to if they're seeing
this it's like
you don't like not everyone's path is
the same and like
you can't like you know if you
if you look at who is the best right
who's been around for 10 years 15 years
like you
think of kendrick cole obviously drake
drake can do everything he's an alien
mm-hmm but like those guys are like
superior mcs like you look at them as
rappers
sex right first and then like you said
like
i think a lot of artists they might put
some [ __ ] out and if it doesn't set the
world on fire it starts to question
they start to question themselves and
then they think oh well now i gotta it's
cause i'm not doing what's popping and
it's like and it's very hard to fall in
that trap because you got to think i
know for me
personally it was hard for me to develop
a team
yeah so this is the first time in my
life well first time in my rapping
career
where i've had a consistent team that
know what the [ __ ] they're doing
right every time else it's been like me
and my friends and that [ __ ] is
frustrating you know what i'm saying
when you in the studio with your homies
and you just
wrote this [ __ ] just wrote your life on
a whole song
and you get in the car and they put on
just like future future
yeah you know what i'm saying or money
man and it's just like damn bro you
don't [ __ ] what i just did
yeah and it's like you ain't got no
malice towards money man then but it
started making you think like okay
should i be doing this you know what i
mean because this is what my people like
so should i be making it to confuse you
yeah so it's very important too to you
know have those people on youtube
once you become comfortable in your own
skin that [ __ ] don't phase you don't
phase you bro because
really anything in life sex that could
be you know that's why i tell people all
the time who go get
whack-ass car payments that they can't
afford and
like yo man like wouldn't you rather
just have a normal car and it'd be paid
off
then worrying about like like be
comfortable in your own skin like
comfortable bro
like it's people's expectations bro we
living in a society where
also instant gratification society
that's what i was about to go into
we living in a society where you're
supposed to be a millionaire 25
or look like or look like it right so
every girl like you broke if you can't
take them to ruth chris
every night right you ain't you ain't
doing it if you can't buy the big chanel
every night when it all
actually riley this ain't real life
[ __ ] is on instagram every day
with 400 000
up the arm you're not walking around
with four hundred thousand dollars every
day like this is
that's not real life but it'll make the
consumer feel like
oh i'm not good enough because this is
what they doing they walking around dior
down every day i think it's even worse
now because they're just normal people
hitting these
edd chicks oh lord bro just looking like
what am i doing wrong they just went to
jail yeah the kid who
rapped about it and put a video out
snitching on himself
i'm like why would you put that out he
literally
snitched on himself he's not looking at
it like that
he's looking at it from the perspective
of this is what i have to do
because this will give me some like this
will give me a post on
yeah no that's what's crazy it's like
bro like you're snitching on yourself
chilling on your show bro
yeah i'll be seeing a lot of these these
scamming scamming rappers like that that
kid from detroit tj whatever his name is
i'm like bro you be snitching on
like it god bless nothing has happened
to him but like i don't know who that is
it's this kid from detroit um his whole
thing is scamming and i'm like yo man
like you're putting a spotlight on
yourself
why if you're active actively still
doing it like chill out bro
yeah so you um
your current situation with that how did
you end up getting on dallas's radar
so when i met cass i had um once i had
don't run from rap just in my mind i
went back to the drawing board
of living like a up-and-coming rapper
right so i always been able to take care
of myself and pay my bills and [ __ ] like
that but i had to go back to the actual
art of
sitting at the computer and writing a
verse right listening to rock him
studying cadences studying schemes
studying four bar
elements you know studying voice
inflection just
playing with different things studying
character when hover hit the
now you know you got to you know hit him
back like that you got him back like
that you right you know what i mean like
when [ __ ] is
playing with their tones and playing
with they their voices
i had to go back and relearn that right
right i had to relearn the art
so i'm watching the artist 16 bars
documentaries every day
so i'm just writing writing writing
writing writing and um
i met cass in september so from
september to march
me and cass would be in the studio every
day
and i would write a verse he'd tell me
that ain't it
i write another one that ain't it you
should say it like this that ain't it
they got to a point where i'm like man
this [ __ ] hating
you know what i'm saying like he want me
to sound like how he think it should
sound but he was really
he was even though some of the [ __ ] i
was writing was dope he was making me a
supreme version of myself
to show me like you can go deeper you
can go further with this
so around march i started making these
songs i made a song
called trapped i made a song called
black jesus in a song called loco
and i heard the i i heard the black
jesus record it's crazy
yeah so black jesus i tell you crazy
story about that that are going to die
that record's not out right no
no it's not out um so i made these songs
in like
three days okay right so cass gets a
text from dallas
cause they're cool um just from you know
industry [ __ ] knowing each other and
everything
he gets a text from dallas like yo i'm
having a
um ox core party tonight at warner you
know some artists tell them to come
through and play some music
right so we go up there and the first
thing i notice is like
everybody's on the same [ __ ] right
they jumping on the table they're
dancing
they're pulling the money out showing
the watch
you know doing all this so i'm just in
the back of the room and i'm just
observing just not
saying nothing you know what i mean so
dallas looks at me
and he's like ain't you that kid that be
freestyling on instagram
i'm like yeah like you ain't got no
music like yeah
so i grabbed aux cord i play black jesus
daryl jones stops the song i'm like what
the [ __ ] is this
shout out to daryl jones he stops the
song like what the [ __ ] is this play
this again i play it again
dallas pulls me outside he like what's
your name i'm like simba we talking for
a minute
next day i wake up cash text me dallas
want to meet at the office
right so it was crazy because
everything we've been doing for those
eight months before i met dallas was
preparation for this meeting for that
meeting yeah you know what i mean so i
had records
ready to go he asked me to freestyle i
was ready to go on this spot i knew how
to talk
in a label i knew how to speak i knew
when to shut up you know what i mean so
it was preparation so
i played dallas about five records he
was like what you gotta do thursday
he was like what you gotta do tuesday i
was like [ __ ] he was like we're going to
new york
like cool tuesday come we shoot out to
new york
i get off the plane hop into uber dallas
tells me to meet him in the studio
i walk in the [ __ ] studio and meek is
in there
i'm like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] right so in
this moment i'm thinking like
okay is they about to try to test me
right now to like
right you never know what that means
like yo look you're gonna battle one of
these dudes on dreams
i'm like this this meek [ __ ] meal you
know what i'm saying this ain't no
average joe this is me [ __ ] meal
you know what i'm saying so i'm like all
right boom i'm cool and i sit back
but he making a song so i'm just sitting
back making a song so dallas like y'all
want to play you something meek
so like simba plug up so i'm like oh
[ __ ]
so i grab the ox play the music
meek look at me like bro you just
inspired me
look at me dead and i like you just
inspired me bro like i haven't heard
nobody rap like this in a long time you
just inspired me
from that day on i started feeling like
i belong
it's nothing nobody could tell me
that's a very secure man right there he
cares about his family
you see that [ __ ] right there i don't
know what just happened he got the alarm
to make sure
his family is [ __ ] straight take
notes i don't know what just happened
no my phone thought we were talking to
it anyway
but no um you say nobody nobody can tell
you [ __ ] nobody can tell me [ __ ] because
it's a
multi-platinum artist and one of my
you know idols i kind of look at in this
[ __ ] telling me to my face
i just inspired him yeah you know so i'm
like
can't nobody tell me [ __ ] yeah right the
next day
i have the meeting i walk in the meeting
and i'm not even knowing who i'm really
in the meeting with till the next day
right so it's me dallas craig cowman
mike kaiser and julie greenwald right
donny chase those are my managers right
now i know these names i don't know how
big they really
are like i know craig comey used to be
like a dj back in the day and i know
julie greenwald worked at like leor
cohen and all these things but i didn't
know how big they actually were right
like these are like the guys
gatekeepers so i play two songs yeah
on the second song in the middle of the
song julie stands up
and gives me a hug she stands up and
hugs me
and she says welcome to atlantic she
looked at dallas she looked at
uh mike and she said don't let him leave
till we get this done
right so now i'm like all right you know
cool but being like i said from the bay
we don't really
know the industry [ __ ] like this so i'm
still learning as i go
so i'm like cool you know cool and we
walk out of the office
and cash is like
you're like do you realize what the [ __ ]
just happened
like [ __ ] julie greenwald just like
what the hell you're like i don't know
who that is
i'm like yeah like yeah so
we on the elevator he breaking down and
she did this she just i'm like oh
[ __ ] you know what i said i'm like i
didn't really know all of this
so we leave new york i get back
and from that day on bro it was just
like
a week later i went to the bt awards
damn i'm sitting
five rows back from the stage and i see
meek again
right and he's like what's up i'm like
oh [ __ ] you know what i'm saying i just
at the time i got a little money but i'm
i just blew like 2500 on the outfit
you know what i'm saying i ain't even
really got it to be in here like this
right now you know what i'm saying
because the deal wasn't done yet so
i'm in the bt [ __ ] and i'm just just
peeping it bro and just getting in my
in my aura like it's time like it's game
time and just from that day bro i just
started walking in the studio with that
confidence and knowing like i'm
competing
with the best of them you know what i
mean i'm competing with the top people
at this point
is it's all about making that great
music yeah i mean
i think the way you just ran through
everything it seemed like it happened
quickly but i mean we're talking
when was the love rants record that was
like 2012
yeah years of preparation 11 12.
so we're talking like this should happen
that's almost 10 years
six yeah even beyond that because it was
like i
was rapping at like nine that shit's
crazy you know what i mean it's just
after high school i'm like
i'm gonna do it professionally yo what's
up man boulette kev here shouting out to
the homies at odd socks
for sponsoring the bootleg cab podcast
and showing us love
man and let me tell you something we
don't take everyone's money
that's not true we'll take everyone's
money but donald trump's but with that
being said we [ __ ] with odd socks all
right
um i've been rocking odd socks for like
eight years now
and um man christmas time coming up make
sure you get you some odd socks
first of all let's talk about these
basics right here
these joints are the most comfortable
socks i've ever put on my feet all right
no design
no license but just crazy so make sure
you get some of those
all right then they got the nickelodeon
they got the uh scarface they got
tapatio
they got wwe how about chef from
southpark you know what i'm saying
whatever you need
shout out stone cold steve austin by the
way these are the socks that i wear when
i uh
drink pbr and yell at my wife
uh anyway um shout out to old dirty
bastard
too go to oddssoxofficial.com right now
all right right now go to
oddssoxofficial.com use the keyword
bootleg kev
and you will receive 20 off at checkout
go do that
yeah do you feel um like how much
pressure like
because like you said you're really
comfortable in your own skin but you
feel like any sort of pressure
as far as like being
like staying staying true to yourself
but also like kind of putting on for the
bay at the same time
um i don't feel pressure because
um i feel like sometimes pressure comes
from
like not having an overall plan of what
you want to do
and i think with
you know being from the bay and sounding
different my overall plan is to bring
something different to the bay
right right so i'm not saying uh
i don't listen to sob slimmie b go to
[ __ ] crazy
right you know what i mean i [ __ ] with i
[ __ ] with uh slimy
i'm saying now we have a lyrical side of
that
yeah so now you have a second option you
can do the slimmies
you could do the next pharaohs you could
do the 40s because we all do different
things but
now we have a simba you know i mean so
if you want lyrical content and you want
some you know
more mainstream sounded things we got
this over here so it's not really to
you know have pressure it's just more so
for me to be able to help people
from the bay who's trying to do the same
thing i'm trying to be that platform
from
for them to be able to come out and do
the same thing
now we had gotten into it over you put a
best bay area rapper of all time lists
together
yeah sure that's 25. that's 25 in my
opinion okay so who who did you have is
your like top five
okay i had uh [ __ ] i had
two short e40 mac dre
uh who did i have in there it was it was
i think i had i want to say you had
somebody that was like pretty high who i
didn't [ __ ]
i never even had heard of oh i can't
even remember i don't got the list off
the top i want to say it was uh
sibo shout out to sibo i think i had
sibo in there
let me see if it's still is it still on
your page nah i took it down it was
getting too hectic i bet it was
yeah it was getting too hectic but um
yeah it was a
top five list and you know kev had hit
me up because
my man g yeah you didn't have g she
wasn't on the list
now i understand g eazy is like you know
not the the the the geez he's a pop star
i get that
but i i think g is a rapper first and i
feel like he's put he's
he's done so much to try to push the bay
area forward even
even as a uh so we got into it because i
was like wait gee how's g not on this
list
in my opinion right how how i looked at
the list
is based off just bay area
rap right the people in the bay area
that just rap
right so g is like you just said a pop
star
so g is able to have the me myself and
eyes
right so you're looking at it through
like the lens of like the bay area
island
yes okay i'm looking at the people that
has to do new parish
and and uh you know the consistent
circuit in the beta [ __ ]
andre [ __ ] tina was who i have for um
the [ __ ] tina
he's a a bay area legend right but
you're never gonna hear nicotina make a
pop
record that he's rapping on he's just
gonna stick to his core you know what i
mean
40 makes big records you know i mean 40
and short is
they out of here that's bigger than the
bay you know what i mean yeah 40 we
can't even talk about that but
just from the perspective of people as
was in the bay and all
they had was rap is what i was basing it
off of
so to me g is bigger than rat g is
somebody that helps
lift rap in the bay so for me to put him
on that list to me was kind of
disrespectful because i would put g up
there with the
the drakes and the you know the the the
pop stars the big he's bigger than that
so that's how that's fair enough who do
you um
like being your like the artist that you
are who did you like
you talked you said earlier that you you
got drake as like number one goat
yeah uh but like who who like growing up
like who was your like go-to
i mean [ __ ] you're obviously a hip-hop
head you know you said you got the gibbs
album number one for the year which i
agree with but like what what was like
the kind of [ __ ] that you kind of
grew up listening to that like kind of
formed your lyrical
your lyrical [ __ ] no definitely um
so there wasn't so let me be okay but
shout out to slimy though because you
know that's that's why i say don't run
from rap because that's rap too yeah for
sure no
i mean we all rapping but um number one
would have to be hove
yeah i feel like um just even the way
i grew up as far as in a family that was
rooted in business and him coming in the
game speaking on ownership and just
being a business-minded person i always
kind of related to that
um number two and i'm not saying these
are my top five
those are the people i listened to the
most growing up
number two would have to be tupac okay
um
my auntie was like a big tupac fan she
thought she was gonna marry this
[ __ ]
you know what i'm saying she loved tupac
and she used to force tupac
on me as a kid like when i was like
three
she used to like make me like learn
like try to learn the lyrics and things
like that so tupac was one
number three would be biggie because i'm
a big fan on like cadences
oh he had the best so when biggie would
hit the when the remy's in the system
ain't no telling when i [ __ ] when i
did some that's what they be yelling
i was infatuated with how the [ __ ] he
fit words
yeah in that you know what i mean and he
kept it fly
and player so biggie was one um four
would be dmx
i love dmx dmx made a lot of songs that
mean a lot to me
dark and hell is high and [ __ ] flesh
in my flesh we're like
man everything bro yeah it was like
everything and as a kid you didn't
really
go through those things yet i went to
the hard knock life tour
and left like jay-z did one song and we
left
because jay closed that tour out and
this was volume two hove and i was just
like
i came here for dmx i was 12. i was like
let's get the [ __ ] out of here yeah
i could beat the line like we came here
for x yeah jay z is cute up there with
his
[ __ ] he had like a benz on stage and
[ __ ] i honestly think x
was like on the verge of being like
bigger than pock oh yeah like because he
had if he didn't have his personal
demons
he would be up there up there
yeah up there up there so i got x4
and number five for me would have to be
50 cent
for sure 50 cent on some rapping now
i said before i get that a lot uh i said
before
um you said jaw rule over 50 when we
talked about first see this is where
this
that got confused growing
up when i was kicking it with the girls
i would play more
ja rule
when i kicked it off right and he was
like what
i'm like bro i'm not saying i don't [ __ ]
with 50 i'm saying i just played a lot
more
i
over 50 like no it's never over 50. it's
just
i listened to jairu a lot more growing
up but then as i got
older and got into you know find the
clip what's up yeah no it's good it's on
uh
it's on youtube yeah we'll find it we'll
put it in there but as i got older
um 50 related to me more but as a kid
the gyro melodies was
was catchy as [ __ ] i did not [ __ ] the
only job well i might [ __ ] with was
vinny vinnie betty vichy man so you
don't [ __ ] with three three six rules
you don't [ __ ] with uh i was out on all
that [ __ ] man
the last temptation nope i like
i'm anybody care of the murdering school
after we wrap this up i was hoping
i was opening murder i was hoping murder
inc was going to be whole job ruling dmx
and then
you know because they were supposed to
they did that record together but yeah
after vinnie vettivich when he started
doing all that i was just like you know
what this ain't for me
bro josh it wasn't for me bro no he had
i mean he had great hit records and like
i went to an old school concert a few
years ago with my wife and
but he lyrically oh it's him in the shot
he's busy though
like you [ __ ] [ __ ] punani vajani your
monologue is getting tired so it's time
to ride so
take off that silly chain put back on
your watch i'm on fire
highly dipped and octane let these
coasts bang let's
coast back back rules career but i'm
straight
benny betty vichy was my [ __ ] shout out
to giant 50 man i know
you know and have issues like i went to
i went to a show and it was him and
ashanti at microsoft theater
and i was like damn this [ __ ]
has some joints for sure
bro yeah big hits but i'm like but at
the same time i'm like i was like
i i wasn't [ __ ] with it like i also
like
outside of country grammar i didn't i
was also i felt the same way about nelly
oh no we're not about to do this no
because i
[ __ ] loved country grammar we're not
about to do this but nellyville and all
that [ __ ]
you didn't like nellyville i'm good man
i liked i'm number one
but like once look as a kid once you
start you didn't like sweating suit
hell
[ __ ] no i don't think anybody liked that
song
besides you listen i like platinum
record country grammar was incredible
fire so the second album wasn't dope it
wasn't for me w
would deliver juice hot in here not for
me come on kev what are we talking about
i'm just saying for me as a kid
i was like man it's
kind of the same way now like we can
have a conversation about drake
and i can respect him i'm not going to
disrespect you
no no i think drake is one of the
greatest of all time okay okay but
i can also say that for the most part as
a grown ass man
i am not in my car riding around
listening to drake
and as a [ __ ] 12 year old 13 year old
kid 14 year old kid
i was not bumping the new nelly in my
discman
oh no man and my disc man there was
[ __ ] because i ride around and listen
to drake now i might not listen
drake is i don't ever want to compare
drake and nelly because drake is a far
more superior artist drake is a gr
listen drake is one of the greatest of
all time
i will say that here but but drake
lyrically
if you get in my car you will not hear
drake
and it's and so you telling me drake
puts out a new
album so you telling me you've never
been in a car by yourself
and you've never played it's been the
best i ever had it's it's been a while
since i've like okay so you've never
played energy by yourself
that that that whole project like i kind
of just
like i'm listening to like [ __ ] that
nobody's heard of for the most part
you get in my car and it's like you
might hear like the fine things you
might hear like beanie siegel the truth
or some [ __ ] like like you can like like
like
i respect drake i respect what he does
but like
i mean i i just it's kind of the same
thing for me it just doesn't tickle my
fancy
for the most part but there are records
like tuscan leather like there's like
drake records
here's why i respect drake so much he's
the greatest here's but here's
one of the reasons why i respect drake
there's multiple reasons why but one of
the main reasons is
drake never runs from rap i don't
disagree right
so drake when pusha
did he not say things are getting a
little too hairy push kind of people
saying this can affect business okay but
did he run from rap then
effectively he ran from rhett but he
didn't he didn't reply
and he said this could affect business
so this is me making a business decision
to not rap he didn't run from red he did
he didn't wrong okay
that's the only black eye besides the
ghost right she didn't run from the rap
he stood on business with that being
said pusha t won the battle
fine right here but here he wanted he
did run from rap though
he did he okay he might have jogged no
it would have been a season
business
here's why i love drake drake will give
you he pranced from
drake will give you god's plan yeah and
give you all murder
listen i guess he'll give you a hit
record and give you 4am in calabasas
so he's understands a lot of people
found me rapping
right and i can do the the big songs but
i'm still going to give them rap
listen most people wouldn't do that bro
drake is
is an all-time great lyrically he can
wrap circles around
99 of all rappers he's incredible yes
i give him all that all day but at the
same time
like i don't know if drake makes music
for me
that's fair for you but i can grab
some so you know if i dig through his
album i'll find some [ __ ] that i [ __ ]
with
yeah and i you know i really like the
laughing cry later record i really like
that right i really love this
last uh album he just put out with the
lucy's the the old song
yeah well yeah that [ __ ] was like that's
the drake i like
i'm like yo i remember when this [ __ ]
was on soundcloud yeah like even for
sure
i think drake is incredible like i said
just in general like
if drake and you know [ __ ] conway put
an album out on the same day
like i'm to go to the conway album first
okay because i'm going to hear the drake
album
i'm on the radio so like the drake i
have to listen to the drake album like i
have to like it's part of my job he's
the biggest artist in the [ __ ] world
but that's why i wasn't riding around
listening to nelly just as a kid if you
went into my cd book
you would not see nellyville in there
see here's what's crazy it might be
burnt it was a burn cd if it was in
there you're disrespectful i definitely
was
disrespectful definitely was a burden
how the [ __ ] did you burn a diamond
album
the only album of nellie's i bought was
uh country grammar
oh i thought you said you burnt country
grammar no no no i bought country
grammar the same day i bought three six
mafia
okay okay that's fair that's fair i was
in san diego outside
diamond i was going to say how did you
burn no country grammar is incredible
okay okay okay we're on the same page
hundred grams it's [ __ ] incredible
here's what's crazy what you just said
if
conway and drake wants to drop album on
the same day i would do the same thing
right
but i would listen to it for different
reasons see i would listen
to kanye conway first to get me in my
zone
right to be able to listen right to open
my ears up
right so when i get to the drake thing
i'm already prepared
for what's about [ __ ] listen i
appreciate drake's music i think
uh take care is the closest thing he has
to a classic
uh i think that i'm still waiting for
him to wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute i don't think he has a classic
like undeniable classic i think take
care spy the closest
the closest thing he has
yeah because it's not a consensus
classic it's a classic to me
like take care is not a classic i i
think it might be
to me okay but i think it's not a
consensus like you know
doggy style no one would tell you doggy
style isn't a classic
can actually take care people will be
like
nah that wouldn't like there are like
like i'm talking we know the albums get
rich or die trying is in the rafters
to make a classic album eminem doesn't
have a consensus classic
he doesn't i agree which one buddy
eminem
come on man i agree but are we talking
[ __ ] marshall mathers lp is a
consensus hip-hop classic
i don't know not at all sir i don't know
not at all
no there was some [ __ ] on that album
i don't know i'm with kev on this one
but eminem is one of the gr
and by the way he's got three really
good albums that are close
great albums slim shows marshall mathers
lp and eminem show
there's arguments to be made that those
three albums are classics but they're
not
consensus classics eminem doesn't have
an album better than get rich or die
trying
period i agree eminem doesn't have an
album better than doggy style or
illmatic
like the the consensus classics are the
ones where there's just no
can you drake i think has two classic
ish
i think take care what are the three
okay
it's they're on the same level i don't
know
i don't know i don't know i would take
take care of a [ __ ] classic i would
take take to me it's a classic but it's
not like
and i'm a hip-hop fan but just this is
why i want to ask this question
because i feel like right we cheat
people with the classic word
and we say people don't have a classic
because they may have a song where
they're singing
no no no no no no i don't think it's
that so when you're sick but i feel like
a lot of times we do that because like
drake said in an album before classic is
just ten of these
you know what i'm saying he's just
saying like i'm like y'all just want me
to rap
so does something not become a hip-hop
classic because it may have a pop record
on it nah you know what i think what
drake's missing
from his uh repertoire is that i think
up until scorpion drake had a really
hard time of
letting us into who he really is wait
wait wait
wait wait i mean that like through his
music and furthermore drake has never
really taken a stand on any sort of
political issues
or like danced out of his comfort zone
when it comes to the content he's
rapping about
is that not fair that's not fair
criticism am i the only one hearing this
by the way let's like let's listen to
this like come on guys
this is on a classic album drug ballad
bro did you hear what he just said
[Music]
so this is a this is on a classic album
this shitty ass eminem song is on
marshall matters
this song sucks did you hear what you
just said
what did i say you just said drake never
opened up until scorpion
i mean like about his purse like he's
talking about bro he's been telling us
about his life
he's talking about [ __ ] is he [ __ ]
he's talking about being heartbroken but
i'm talking about talking about his
no idea what drake's political leanings
are i don't know how it feels about
social issues
i don't know well maybe that's okay
that's different
i have no idea who like i don't know
where i don't know his opinion on a lot
of things
outside of he likes fat [ __ ] with
girls with fat asses that used to work
at hooters you know what i'm saying
no no drake also is the kind of guy i
would suspect drake also subscribes to a
lot of only fans accounts for sure
listen drake opens up about a lot of
things does he not
how many only fans account subscription
do you think you guys it's not my
business i think drake's in the dm's are
only fans like yo what's up girl this is
drake no for real it is
i just wanted to support drake has three
classes give you this 14.99
what are the three i think take care
yeah if you're reading this too late
i uh you know what i can't i i know a
lot of people say that but yeah he
didn't write yeah
nothing was the same nothing was the
same as the other the two for me it's
nothing i think nothing were the same as
his best album personally me too but i
think take care is the one that's like
there's not one song you can skip on
take care
i don't disagree it's not like it's a
great album you can't skip one song
we can skip i think that's the only i
think in the last uh
you know recently let's say the last 10
years
2012. so let's say the last eight years
i think that the only
i'm not saying that there's not other
classics because i do think
freddie gets a mad lib god classic but
these are classics that like well
kendrick has
three classes no listen i was gonna say
the only consensus
non-deniable classic album that's come
out is good command city
because to pimp a butterfly is a very
controversial album it's very polarized
that's classic
i don't disagree with you i think
kendrick dropped three classics in a row
i mean through the lens of like
nobody is going to say that good kid
matt goodkid mad city is up there with
good richard i try yeah to pimp a
butterfly is
one of the most polarizing albums ever i
think it's a classic
thanks i actually think it's probably
kendrick's best album
in my opinion i think damn no that's his
worst album in my opinion out of the
three but
because but damn is a classic in my
opinion he kind of meshed both no i
agree but damn is a classic yeah so
for so for me just but out of those
three i put it
i go you know either good kid matt said
or to pimp a butterfly
you can go the way they came out but but
i think the only
album in the last eight years that we
look at and we're like
that is a classic nobody can say [ __ ]
is that album now i have opinions on
other projects that i think are classics
okay but i just mean like
there's just those albums that you're
like would you say
my twisted dark fantasy of course that
was 2010
that was 2010. that to me is the best
album ever no that was 2016.
2010. i mean connie's my favorite artist
what about watch the throne
no you don't think that's a classic not
a classic i think it's a good album
there's some good [ __ ] on there
can't argue that i actually think i
think jesus is a classic
i think jesus changed sonics and hip hop
i agree i think astral world is a
classic but guess what
i'm talking about just like you like
there nobody could say [ __ ] about good
kid mad city yeah
no i agree i'm saying damn is my
favorite because
maybe maybe forest hills drive
maybe and i don't maybe
maybe but it's not on the same level as
good kid mad city see what good kid
like it's so dope because it was like
not only his first
introduction but it was just so classic
right but for me as an
artist the psyche of an artist is hard
to
continue to do that right so for him to
come with something as polarizing as the
pimp a butterfly
and then mesh to pimp a butterfly and
good kid mad city into a dam
yeah you know commercially as an artist
had his biggest records
yeah like that's a hard thing and i i
don't want to say that there's not other
classic albums in that eight year span
i think my crazy life by yg is a classic
but i think
i think that i don't know if
[ __ ] no i definitely think my
crazy life
i i agree but i don't think people like
if you talk to [ __ ] in new york
they might be like nah that [ __ ] was
just all right
i mean like yo these are this is a hall
of fame album nobody's gonna say [ __ ]
when you put that up there on the mantle
yeah no one will say [ __ ] if my
beautiful dark twists of fantasy is on
the bed
or reasonable doubt or a good kid get
rich
yeah so i mean look eminem's all-time
great and i personally
don't think he's got a a consensus
classic i agree
i agree he has great albums but as far
as just a classic from top to bottom
in my opinion i don't know yeah i don't
know
but without the eminem though i think
eminem shows my favorite m
m album eminem show is my favorite
eminem album definitely i even like
the encore album as well though encore
had some [ __ ] on it that was like it had
some really bad [ __ ]
like some of the worst [ __ ] i ever heard
but it had some [ __ ] that i loved he had
some dope [ __ ]
he had some like that that uh that that
he just had some [ __ ] i was in a really
toxic
relationship yeah and he had some [ __ ] i
was like yeah
this [ __ ] talking to me um all right so
you got
this is going to come out after your
2-chan single comes out yes sir um
i know you have a lot of records you're
sitting on yes um
what is the like what's next for you
obviously we got the change project the
videos out
or the change single rather um
is this leading into a project
don't run from rep don't run from
responsibilities and principles um
the name of the hours don't run from
rape
no no he jogged from rap he didn't run
drake didn't run from reps
he ran from pushing it you're right he
ran from pusha t he stood on business he
didn't
run from right he ran from pushing shout
out to pusha t2 because that's the big
homie pushing
one of the greatest of all time facts
but shout out to drake because he didn't
run from rap he stood on business
but like i was saying um yeah the
project is called don't run from rap
um it's coming very soon very very soon
before the end of the year
um i'm very excited about it um i
haven't dropped a
project since 2015. wow yeah
so i've been like doing a lot of um
you've been training you've been in the
gym
yeah so this is like the first thing
i've dropped in five
years you know like i'm hella excited
about it bro um
can we get a ep with you and cash oh
we're gonna do an album
okay yeah we're gonna do it oh mr
already in the in the works
i know i've heard a lot of records on
with you two together that are [ __ ]
nuts yeah like we already doing that
shout out my brother jason cash straight
out of carson
delano's best you feel me shout out my
boy but um
yeah the uh project is coming um got two
chains on there
um money bag yo is on there
um i got a record with this girl named
giannis
okay who's on atlantic as well it's
actually one of my favorite records
on the project um but really man my
overall plan bro is kind of what we was
talking about before is to
you know bring a new platform from the
bay i look at my music as like a
stepping stone
to be able to do bigger things and you
know the content world is crazy right
now
it's crazy so i talk to a lot of my
friends just about
you know movie ideas we had we work on a
lot of scripts
me and one of my good friends we got a
script we was talking about called dad
friends you know what i mean just about
some i don't want to say it but it's
some dope [ __ ] they don't give out the
idea someone will take it
but another one of my friends we got
another movie we working on called sugar
another one of my friends we was working
on a small
docu-series about a uh san francisco cop
who started beef in san francisco
you know what i mean so it's a lot of
these stories from the bay area the hook
and that actually did that actually
actually happened a big time beef in san
francisco so there was a cop who started
a rat beef
no not a rat beef street beef
like on purpose just to some deep [ __ ]
oh
some deep [ __ ] it's some real deep [ __ ]
uh you got stories like the hook
mitchell story
you know what i mean a lot of people
don't know the paypal mafia
was was was started in [ __ ] debate
when hey i feel like the bay everything
was started in the bay yeah
like you know and then everyone just
steals it a lot of these stories don't
get towed
so being in a era where content is king
where tv shows and youtube shows and all
these things i want to be someone to
highlight these stories
hey man that's the way man have your
have your eggs in all baskets you said
that your parents
came from a real estate background yeah
do you do and dabble in the real estate
game at all um it's tricky my mom always
gets me into it i just got my first crib
out here in l.a
um my mom's are you overpaid no i
actually got a good deal
and um i don't want to say where i live
but it's a cool area
everything's [ __ ] expensive out here
man if you dig bro
you just gotta be on the outskirts of
the valley no i know
that's where i'm looking i'm looking
like tahunga and all kinds of little
spots i'm like damn when you right in
the center everything it gets pricey but
um
yeah my mom is like heavy like on me
about real estate all the time but i'm
just somebody that's so
caught up in my dream i feel like i
can't really
you got to put blinders on right i can't
put energy to nothing
but pursuing what i'm trying to do right
now because i know this is what's going
to help me be able to do that later not
for sure and plus
the market's at like an all-time high
it's gonna go down yeah
no for sure well look don't run from rap
coming before the end of the year
definitely big homie with two chains is
out shout out to two chains too man
that's that's the big homie shout out
sleepy roll shout out tech shout out to
the whole true camp from the homies
right there
boom simba makes you follow him at the
real symbol on instagram
perfect